I have some really great video for you
today from a top contender for the most
delusional Trump voter in to come India
in the United States last week during a
live stream that I did on YouTube and
twitch we happen to overlap with some of
Donald Trump's Magga rally in Florida
and Fox News sent a reporter actually
let's call him a guy with a microphone I
think better said they sent a guy with a
microphone to a restaurant in Boca Raton
Florida the day after the rally and they
happened to come across a business owner
of a security company this is all self
professed I don't know if any of this
stuff is true a guy who says he owns a
security company who hires lots of
veterans who says he used to be a
Democrat but is now fully backing Trump
this guy says he is all in with Trump
because he's patriotic and he supports
Family Values and he's honest this is
Trump and has integrity of character and
has delivered on his promises I present
to you today the man that might be the
most delusional Trump voter in the
country at least a top contender for
that position and notice as you watch
this video how sure of himself this man
seems sir what's your name and what do
you do my name is Ronnie Joseph and I
run a security company
we run security coming we were talking
you hire a bunch of vets we appreciate
that for sure you know you used to be a
Democrat now you're a Republican you
support the president why that change
and why do you support President Trump
well for me it's really quite simple
it's about family values is about being
a patriotic American and it just comes
down to being honest and truthful to who
you are that's what I put you know
that's what I value family values
honesty integrity character and that's
everything that President Trump
represents you feel like he's delivered
on the promises that he absolutely
absolutely he has facts do not matter
Trump is patriotic and supports family
values is honest has integrity of
character and has delivered on promises
is there anything that guy said that's
true is it even true that this guy used
to be a Democrat maybe that's the one
thing the guy said that it's true he's
with Trump on the issue of Family Values
Trump who has had not only endless
affairs and seems to barely even know
some of his children but has paid off
some of his mistresses was involved with
people whose names I can't even say
because as soon as you say certain names
you get demonetised
on YouTube but I think you all know who
I'm talking about those family values
Trump's family values have this voter
gushing over Donald Trump he's with
Trump over Trump's honesty Trump is the
most dishonest president by number of
Lies of any president that we are aware
of
he's with Trump over integrity of
character Trump operates like a con man
wanna me mafia boss there is nothing
further from integrity of character than
Donald Trump
this guy is with Trump because Trump has
delivered on his promises what he was
gonna fix health care and get rid of
Obamacare didn't happen he was gonna
build a wall didn't happen he was gonna
fix trade that seems to have gone the
opposite direction he was going to
improve the reputation of the u.s.
around the world
no the US isn't even included in many
important conversations happening
internationally because of Donald Trump
in the Oval Office the only value that
this guy seems to share with Donald
Trump is extraordinary hypocrisy that is
the one area where they seem to overlap
this is the twilight zone this is why
facts don't matter and this is why I've
been saying for years we can't waste our
time on these people imagine that you
meet someone who says listen I think
Trump's a scumbag liar who's
embarrassing the US around the world but
I'm gonna be honest with you his tax
plan is good for me personally so I'll
probably vote for him we can work with
that okay we can talk about you know
listen even if it seems like Trump's tax
plan is good for you because you've got
more money in your pocket it's actually
not good for you in that by hurting
others it creates societal cost like my
point is we can have a conversation with
someone who believes that if you meet
someone who says I love Trump he's
honest he has integrity of character he
has family values that I agree with he
fulfilled his promises by I mean that's
a conversation ender there is no point
and it's actually so absurd
this video that I had people tweeting me
over the weekend saying David this guy
has to be a plant but I actually think a
plant would be less ignorant we cannot
win by convincing these people we have
to win despite them period and we might
not sadly there may be enough tens of
millions of people like that guy who
voted for Trump in 2016 and are going to
vote for him again in 2020 that we may
lose and that's why get-out-the-vote is
so important let me know what you think
about this video leave a reply if you're
watching on YouTube otherwise send me a
tweet at D Pakman follow me there as
well we'll take a quick break so much to
talk about today back from Thanksgiving
and much has happened I used to love
those sugary breakfast cereals and then
I grew up and realized that they're full
of sugar and excess carbs and I probably
shouldn't be having them this episode is
sponsored by magic spoon which is a new
cereal company they figured out a way to
recreate those favorite childhood
cereals with zero sugar twelve grams of
protein and only three grams of net
carbs per serving four flavors are
available based on the classics cocoa
cinnamon frosted and fruity they have a
variety pack that lets you try all of
them they've recreated the taste and the
texture of classic sugary cereal but it
tastes so incredible that you wouldn't
guess that it didn't have all that sugar
its keto friendly gluten free grain free
soy free and low carb my favorite is
cocoa I admit although I've tried all of
them and they're all pretty good cocoa
though has a special place in my heart
magic spoon dot-com slash Pakman is the
place to grab a variety pack and try it
today use the code Pakman at checkout to
get free shipping magic spoon is so
confident in their product that it comes
with a 100% happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund you your money no questions asked
go to magic spoon comm slash Pakman and
use the code PA k ma n for free shipping